Hey guys, I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop not too long ago
We showed you an easy way to make fire snakes
Using some sugar, some baking soda, and just a little bit of alcohol as a fuel. well in that video a ton of people
Commented saying that they wanted to see what happened if we took the burned black fire snake and put in liquid nitrogen
Or in a vacuum chamber so today, We're gonna try both, for the first step of course.
We need to make our fire snakes, so I've got some of our powdered sugar and baking soda mixed up here
Let's add a little bit of alcohol on top of our sand pour on some piles and light them off
There we have it some fire snakes
And now let's test out see what happens if we put one of these in a vacuum chamber and what happens if we put one
In some liquid nitrogen, let's do the vacuum chamber first
These are so lightweight.
They are mostly air and that's the kind of thing that usually reacts on a vacuum chamber
But I don't know if we have any closed cells all the air might just escape right out of it
Let's find out all right here. We go fire snakes in a vacuum chamber three, two, one
Some vapor coming off of it
Hmm other than that little bit of vapor
I'm not seeing any change or even movement
We have a pretty complete vacuum already
But
Not a lot has happened well. Let's let some pressure back in
Feels exactly the same still lightweight very crumbly
Basically turns to dust immediately
Really, not a lot of change, so I guess it's a very open celled structure so all of the air
That's inside is able to just get sucked out, and then you just have a sort of structure full of vacuum
But not air. Oh, well all right. We've tried our fire snake in the vacuum chamber
Let's see what happens if we dip our fire snake into some liquid, nitrogen
To try it's so lightweight
Just kind of float on top of maybe not looks like it's kind of absorbing it and sinking in
Like halfway sunk in that's something
But do you think it's sort of soaking in some of the liquid nitrogen so as a test
I'm gonna try taking it, out putting on the table, and then just smashing it right away
It might just kind of spray out some liquid nitrogen. Let's try it
Heh!
Well it did kind of spray everywhere the the fire stink itself has so little cohesion
It just kind of turns to dust when you smoosh it
I think the liquid nitrogen in there gave it a little added mass and it just popped everywhere. It's just gone immediately
I'm going to try that again. This is definitely heavier. It has the weight of liquid nitrogen and it starts freezing my glove
Squish!
Hey, you actually squeeze liquid nitrogen out of it like a sponge
So yeah it goes fast. It just explodes everywhere you go a little slower, and it squeezes it
It's like a sponge
Splat. Splat, splat, splat.
Still got all of that nitrogen inside it
See what happens if I pour a little bit of the liquid nitrogen
Right on to it
It just soaks it up
Which is interesting most stuff that we pour liquid nitrogen on to it?
Just has the Leidenfrost effect and it skitters across it and doesn't really get absorbed but this stuff
It really just absorbs it like a sponge
Make sure it's getting soaked and then I'm just gonna smash it. 3 2 1
And it just turns to dust, it's gone
Well there you have it some fire snakes in a vacuum chamber
Which really didn't do too much and in some liquid nitrogen, which didn't make them any more fragile, but they did absorb the liquid
Nitrogen, which is something we haven't seen very much most materials
Don't absorb the liquid nitrogen they just sort of either float on top of it or the leident frost effect makes it so the liquid
Nitrogen doesn't soak into them
But this stuff really soaked it in and we got some cool effects and smashed it in slow motion
So it's pretty fun if you have any cool ideas of things you want to see us try let us know down in the comments
Especially if it involves combining other projects. We've already done
Thanks for joining us for this video today and remember to come gear yourself up with products and merch at thekingofrandom.com
See you there
Not a lot has happened except for the fact that it now has no air resistance as it tumbles around inside so it moves faster